One day, Robin went into the forest alone.
He came to a bridge across a river.
He began to cross the bridge.
As he did so, a man began to cross the bridge from the other side of the river.
The two men met in the middle of the bridge.
There was not enough room for them to pass.
"I was on the bridge first," Robin said.
"You were not," the other man said.
He was much taller than Robin. "I was on the bridge first."
The two men fought for a long time. They hit one another hard with their staffs.
Then, the tall man hit Robin very hard. He fell off the bridge and into the river.
At this moment, Will and some of Robin's men came out of the forest.
"No," Robin answered as he climbed out of the river.
"Who are you?" Robin asked the tall man. "What are you doing in the forest?"
"I am looking for Robin Hood," the tall man said.
"Oh! Why are you looking for him?"
"I want to join his band of outlaws. I want to be one of his men."
"Why do you want to become an outlaw?" Robin asked him.
"I am already an outlaw," the tall man said.
"Prince John took my lands and gave them to one of his men. Now, I have no home."
Robin shook his hand. "Welcome. I am Robin Hood," he said.
"I need strong and brave men like you. You may join my band of outlaws."
"What is your name?" Will asked him.
"John Little," the tall man said.
Robin laughed. "You are so tall," he said, "we will call you Little John!"
And this was how Little John became one of Robin's best friends.